Bonjour à vous et bienvenu pour cette nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui nous allons parler du programme du candidat qui a été choisi pour représenter le Parti Socialiste : Benoît Hamon.
Son objectif est plutôt simple : il souhaite faire battre à nouveau le coeur de la France et ça, ça passe selon lui par 3 axes.
Réaliser un procès social et écologique.
Rendre la République bienveillante et humaniste.
Et que la France soit indépendante et protectrice
Benoît Hamon souhaite la mise en place d'une VIème République.
Il souhaite remettre le citoyen au coeur de l'Etat, en instaurant la possibilité d'un "49.3 citoyen",
en lui laissant décider de l'attribution d'une partie du budget de l'Etat (5 milliards max),
et en lui accordant le pouvoir d'écrire la loi de manière collaborative, via des amendements citoyens.
Il souhaite aussi globalement rénover l'appareil politique français.
Cela passe selon par une réforme du Sénat,
une limitation du cumul des mandats dans le temps,
la limitation d'un président de la République à un unique septennat, à la place des quinquennats,
ou la modernisation du Conseil Constitutionnel, pour que les anciens Présidents de la République ne s'y retrouvent pas par défaut.
Enfin il est pour plus de transparence pendant les élections,
et à ce titre, il souhaite que chaque candidat publie la liste de ses donateurs de plus de 2.500€, pour éviter les conflits d'intérêts.
Il veut par ailleurs reconnaître le rôle du vote blanc en lui permettant d'annuler une élection, si il est majoritaire.
La grosse réforme de Benoît Hamon, c'est le revenu universel d'existence pour définir un nouveau rapport au travail.
Comment ça se passerait ?
Dès 2018, le RSA serait à hauteur de 600€ et versé automatiquement à tous les ayant-droits,
avec à côté un revenu d'existence versé à tous les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans.
Pour décider du reste (montant, financement, calendrier),
il souhaite une grande conférence citoyenne pour fixer le périmètre du revenu universel.
Ce revenu sera ensuite étendu à l'ensemble de la population.
L'idée c'est qu'à terme, il atteindra la somme de 750€.
La seconde réforme dont on a beaucoup entendu parlé,
c'est la légalisation par une distribution encadrée du cannabis,
pour tuer les traffics à la source.
Niveau emploi, il s'oppose à ce qui peut fragiliser la position du salarié
et veut donc abroger la loi travail,
mais aussi fortifier le statut des indépendants, en luttant contre les entreprises ubérisées qui font du salariat déguisé,
et en créant un "statut unique de l'actif" pour dépasser les distinctions salarié - indépendant, pour que ces questions ne se posent plus.
Parce qu'il considère qu'en France les bénéfices vont trop souvent du côté des dividendes et non de l'investissement,
il souhaite moduler l'impôt sur les sociétés, en fonction de la part des bénéfices réinvestis dans l'entreprise.
Par ailleurs, il propose la mise en place d'une taxe robot dans les entreprises remplaçant les travailleurs par des machines,
puisque le bénéfice créé bénéficie principalement aux actionnaires.
Il veut supprimer les rémunérations des patrons, dépourvues de lien avec l'amélioration des résultats de l'entreprise.
Il s'oppose aussi farouchement à l'évasion fiscale.
Il veut mettre en place un compte-rendu public,
pays par pays, pour toutes les entreprises,
renforcer les moyens de poursuite des fraudeurs,
et adapter la fiscalité française pour que de grands groupes comme Amazon n'échappent plus à l'impôt.
Il souhaite d'ailleurs refondre l'impôt sur le revenu : le rendre plus progressif, entre autres,
en augmentant le nombre de tranches pour une meilleure individualisation.
Il envisage de remplacer l'ISF et la taxe foncière par un unique impôt sur le patrimoine.
Et pour que la transition écologique ne dépende pas du marché,
il prévoit d'instaurer une TVA attractive pour les produits à faible empreinte carbone,
et de rendre la fiscalité incitative pour guider l'épargne des Français vers des investissements verts.
Point primordial de son programme, Benoît Hamon souhaite la mise en place d'un plan zéro déchets pour le pays
via la lutte contre les gaspillages alimentaires,
un combat contre l'obsolescence programmée
et l'obligation des métropoles de recycler 50% de leurs déchets produits annuellement à l'horizon 2022.
Et puisqu'on parle d'objectif, il souhaite l'utilisation de 50% d'énergie renouvelable par le pays dès 2025
et la sortie du diesel d'ici à 2050.
Il veut aussi sanctuariser les biens communs, air, eau et sol,
pour les protéger contre toute dégradation ou risque de captation privée.
Dans cette logique de protection, il souhaite appliquer le principe de précaution
en interdisant les perturbateurs endocriniens et les pesticides dangereux.
Et plutôt que de continuer avec les pesticides, il propose d'investir pour développer le bio et l'agro-écologie.
Il souhaite la création d'un nouveau service public, la brigade de lutte contre les discriminations
pour vérifier régulièrement les pratiques des structures publiques et privées en la matière.
Pour lutter contre les inégalités homme-femme, il propose, en plus d'un renforcement des sanctions en cas de non-respect de l'égalité salariale,
l'extension de la PMA aux femmes seules et aux couples homosexuels,
l'augmentation du délai de prescription de viol, du nombre de centres de planning familial,
ou l'extension du congé paternité.
Pour la santé, outre la mise en place d'un droit à la santé universel,
il souhaite mettre en place le droit de mourrir dans la dignité, pour les personnes atteintes d'une maladie incurable.
A l'échelle internationale, Benoît Hamon souhaite faciliter l'accueil des réfugiés via
la création d'un visa humanitaire pour ouvrir une voie d'accès légale, sécurisée, mais temporaire, au territoire français aux personnes en situation de détresse humanitaire,
et l'élimination des obstacles à l'intégration des demandeurs d'asile,
en leur donnant une autorisation de travailler après 3 mois de présence sur le territoire
et un accès renforcer à l'apprentissage de la langue française.
Vis-à-vis des accords internationaux de libéralisme économique,
Benoît Hamon suspendra, s'il est élu, l'accord de libre-échange avec le Canada
et veillera à ce que le TAFTA ne voit pas le jour.
Au niveau européen, il ne remet pas en cause les traités,
mais souhaite négocier avec les partenaires européens une annulation de la dette des pays du Sud de l'Europe
et l'harmonisation fiscale entre pays, par :
un rapprochement du taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés,
un taux plafond de TVA,
et une coordination contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale.
L'idée est, par exemple, de créer un nouvel impôt, européen, sur les GAFA et les multinationales
pour augmenter le budget de l'Union Européenne.
J'espère que le programme est maintenant plus clair pour vous.
Comme d'habitude, dans les sources le lien vers son programme, complet.
Et comme d'habitude, je vous invite à le consulter,
parce qu'en 5 minutes, on passe forcément à côté de certains points.
On se retrouve très très vite pour le prochain candidat.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Merci à tous !
Merci notamment aux Tippeurs pour financièrement soutenir le projet !
Love
Peace
Tchao !